[Music]
hello and welcome to year-in-review a
chance to look back at 20 19 s biggest
news stories well joining me are the
editor of The Times Literary Supplement
Stig Abel the Telegraph's associate
editor Camilla domine the sons political
editor Tom Newton done and the editor of
The Londoner at the Evening Standard
Aisha has a recur so welcome to all of
you now when we first sat down to make
this programme we asked all of our
guests here to choose their story of the
year and their decision was unanimous it
was of course the brexit election so
we're going to get to that in a moment
but through the course of the hour we're
also going to be looking at the big
stories from outside Westminster our
panels heroes and villains of the year
as well as their predictions for 2020
but before all of that let's go back to
brexit and the election and Tom I'm
going to kick off with you a huge year
politically what do you see is the most
important facet of this huge story well
there was only brexit really in British
politics this year it begun with it in
its ending with it and for me the
absolutely central figure in all this
was Boris Johnson and therefore the
story there has to be Boris Johnson
election as tornado winning the tour
leadership contest because really
everything else flowed from that he won
the contest by promising he would get
brexit through no matter what on time it
didn't quite happen like that but with
that very sort of strong powerful
message that's what got him elected
that's what also than allowed him to tee
up this great Parliament versus the
people's struggle which allowed him to
force the journal action which became a
very popular mantra to Malaysian as we
know he won it with a landslide but the
one really interesting thing about that
the rise and rise and rise of Boris
Johnson is it really wasn't predestined
at all a series of different sliding
door events things that what ifs think
didn't happen Teresa may not winning
three different meaningful votes twenty
Labour MPs going a different way ten DUP
mp6 cetera et cetera all these sort of
series of Celtic happenings all
precipitated in foresters victory and is
a former labor adviser
you may not naturally be a big fan of
Boris Johnson but would you acknowledge
there's been an extraordinary
achievement by him to pull off what he
has this year yeah I mean the the result
was far bigger than anybody em you know
predicted lots of us were hoping for a
hung parliament we're thinking maybe a
majority orb around 20 but that was a
huge landslide I do have to say one
thing though I mean everybody is saying
yes he's a formidable campaigner and he
ran a great campaign he was also up
against the most repellant person on the
doorstep which was Jeremy Corbyn and I
think that they had a electoral
advantage by being up against somebody
who was just pulling so badly and was
turning people off in their droves so in
a way yes Boris Johnson won but I think
Jeremy Corbyn helped him a lot okay and
we're going to come back to labor and
and how they fed this year in a moment
but come in and let's move on to you
because I know that your peak of this
brexit election issue has been at the
the moment that you believe that those
pieces of the puzzle started falling
into place for Boris Johnson well I
think it was when he secured the brexit
deal against all odds and Tom them was
talking about the leadership campaign
which seems like about 50 years ago now
but I remember going around some of the
hustings particularly up in the north
and the weight of expectation on this
politician was huge people were saying
that there was support even in the
leadership because he would quotes get
brexit done and it's no wonder that that
carried on being the campaign slogan but
it really was this idea that if he
wasn't going to deliver then politically
he would be finished it was such a
high-risk high-reward strategy really
that he took in order to say that he
would die in a ditch and that this would
be his lasting legacy and when he went
out to Brussels it's hard to remember
now because so much has happened since
but you had politicians like Rory
Stewart calling this you this brexit
deal a unicorn
it was never going to happen in fact the
entire premise of the RET rebel Tory
rebellion the the remain a Tory
rebellion was this idea that he didn't
want to deal and it wasn't going to get
one and this was all a strategy to keep
no deal on the table
and in fact when he came back from
Brussels was something which okay people
said looked a bit like Theresa Mays deal
in a blonde wig but at the same time
managed to remove the back stop I
thought that was quite a seminal moment
in finally this politician who had been
underestimated countless times actually
delivering on something but he delivered
it by doing something he said he
wouldn't do which also characterizes
Boris Johnson that he has a tremendous
amount of front and you need that a lot
in politics he says stuff and people
believe him he said he wouldn't create a
border down the middle of the Irish Sea
and that's precisely what he conceded
and he recognizes that getting a deal
this may well happen actually next year
as well getting a deal being able to say
you've got a deal is more important than
the detail of itself and and you know
eventually that may come back to haunt
him it may come back to court the court
the Tory Party it may hold all of us
collectively in this country but he
recognized pragmatically that the most
important thing was getting a deal that
he could stand behind even though it did
the thing he said it didn't wasn't going
to do I think you could say from his
perspective that he was at the point of
negotiations where he was and Tom talk
tell you about sliding doors and had
Gove not knifed him in the back during
the original leadership campaign and who
knows whether it would have been
different whether the negotiation would
have been carried out differently but
what I think that getting that deal said
and I appreciate what you're saying
about his flaws which will no doubt come
unraveled in the coming months was this
idea that he did not want to be
responsible for a failure of States
craft because people had said he can't
do the detail and he is an estate ceman
and look at him as foreign secretary and
I think in emerging from Brussels
triumphant even though it may be a
Pyrrhic victory was hugely significant
in the path that then led to his
landslide election quick word about to
resume as well
I mean if it's been a good year for
Boris Johnson it's been her annus
horribilis isn't it well I think that
would be the view from a slightly
short-term perspective actually I think
history might write it just a little bit
differently remember she got really
close to getting this deal over the line
she lost the mast last-minute vote by 58
votes that actually only means 30 29 mph
in the other way in a country that's in
a polymer 650th that's quite small so
she got most of the deal done couldn't
get at Clover line Boris's showmanship
right place right time
did get it over line but then we'll say
go forward to the general election
although since the Tories won most of
them were down to tiny labour majorities
the reason why they're down to tiny
mobility is a few hundred here if you
did there is good reason May took huge
chunks out of them in 2017 so she said I
did the hard work
you could argue and for a sweeps in to
take the glory of the end and she's
better suited to her roles and she I
mean she the great thing about threes in
May was she was not suited to be prime
minister because many of the qualities
that people who like Boris Johnson see
in him she simply doesn't have and I
usually will come to your pick of this
big story and you're choosing to focus
on the party that's close to your heart
on labour and how they dealt with things
was brexit their undoing do you do I
think there was a number of things I
think the fact that the on the biggest
issue of the day the you know the
political fight which is defined a
generation in many ways they were facing
in two different directions they were
trying to be all things to all people
and they pleased nobody in the end we
hemorrhaged a lot of remaining
supporters and we also lost a lot of
leave supporters and I think the fatal
mistake was that the party tried to push
the argument that this was not going to
be a breaks at election when everybody
knew it was going to be a breaks at
election and to go in with a neutral
position so the question that really
sort of skewered Jeremy Corbyn again and
again during the debates and all the
interviews he couldn't answer the
question so if there's going to be a
second referendum that you are now
pushing for how are you going to
campaign and how you can avert
he could not answer that question but
how important was that given that he did
try to keep remain as and levers his
voters have also split did he not have I
think she left it to lead I mean Jeremy
Corbyn is actually a man who has shown
himself to be capable of leadership on
quite contentious issues take the issue
of economic austerity when he first
became leader of the Labour Party the
dominant narrative was that we did need
austerity and changed that by showing
leadership he didn't show leadership on
the brakes at issue partly a lot of
people think because he was divided
himself he was well known as a historic
brexit he often voting in the lobbies
with a lot of the the Arts you know er
GM members but it
wasn't just breaks that we have to be
honest about the fact there were two
other issues the manifesto was popular
to many because there was just so much
in it it was a bonanza giveaway it was a
wish list it was Black Friday of
political policies and people just
didn't believe it it became incredible
in the literal sense of the word
and anybody who knows like labor history
is labor governments that are our
opposition who are trying to get into
government have to look like they're
credible on the economy and the final
thing was that he was toxic on the on
the doorstep his personal ratings were
absolutely you know through the floor
and from issues like national security
was he a patriot his links with
terrorism anti-semitism I understand
this is that in 2017 that was all true
had a chance of winning whereas I think
because the polling towards the end did
suggest I spoke to a cabbie this week
which I know sounds like a cliche and he
said well I saw the polling I saw how
close Corbin got and I went out to the
polling station a quarter to ten because
I thought my vote really counts I don't
think there was that degree of peril in
2017 okay and the other area that we
haven't touched on is your pic from 2016
onwards you'd have to imagine there'd be
a moment for the Lib Dems the 48%
Labour's position as we know veer
between being yester brexit - we're not
really sure - maybe the Tories were
fairly quickly onto the s with the
policy of brexit so there should have
been a party for the 48% and there
wasn't in the years immediately after
breakfast it and the European elections
happened and the Lib Dems did quite well
and the idea had the stain of coalition
been washed off them were people willing
to forgive and vote Lib Dem and zephyr
haven't got a bit excited Joe Swinson
got excited a couple of polls put her
near twenty percent of the vote maybe
they would become a major third-party
again and then it just fell apart what
was the mistake was it the policy of
revoking article 50 I think that country
- what some brick cities would say
people a lot of people who voted remain
do believe in democracy and the problem
with the Lib Dem position was the idea
of revoking out of hand which intellect
you saying that corporates position
intellectually you can kind of justify X
they wanted something clean they wanted
something that's absolutely
straightforward
but in doing so there's a bunch of
people who thought well we had this
elected this referendum I didn't agree
with it I didn't agree with the result
you but you cannot simply remove it from
history and also two incredible leaders
as in uncredible leaders in a Tim phone
followed by Jason synthetic or Swisher
then I went to the loser and see but but
neither and really cut through Joseph is
a bit wooden but maybe a bit sort of
young inexperienced Tim found quite a
lot of people had some quite
professional views on a liberal on a
liberal views on gay rights and they
just simply failed to cut through but
you know what really trying to it wasn't
the Lib Dems what lost it was the
two-party system won't want it yet again
the two-party system that binary choice
that defines everything British politics
the last 300 years has come back ok
other things that Joseph Winston made a
fatal mistake they were to they over
claimed too much I mean it just was not
believable she was like I'm gonna be the
next prime minister I'm gonna win a
majority like that is right there's more
chance of me winning America's next top
model to be honest than curiously as
well despite her kind of right on
approach she was very much tainted by
the fact that she had been apparently
complicit in the austerity introducing
by the coalition government and I don't
think she expected to be quite so
damaged of okay well we must move on to
other subjects do stay with us because
coming up we're going to have some of
the other big stories of the year picked
over including a prince under fire a
presidency under scrutiny and a planet
under threat that's coming up after the
break
[Music]
welcome back you're watching
year-in-review here on Sky News now time
to step out of the Westminster bubble
and look at some of the other big
stories of the year and commit we're
going to start with you because outside
of politics you're beat for a long time
has been that the Royals and it's been a
big year for them and not always for the
right reasons
that's right it was a double whammy
really when all of the allegations
concerning the Duke of York's links to
convicted pedophile Jeffrey Epstein came
to the surface and that happened for two
reasons I think first of all following
Epstein's suicide in prison which then
engendered another raking over of all of
the allegations more people coming
forward to suggest that he had behaved
improperly but equally this enormous act
of self sabotage in Prince Andrew doing
the news night interview now that
weekend which came in the middle of
political melee anyway meant that my
workload was doubled didn't go home for
about 12 days is that why he's picked it
that's why I picked it yeah it was a
very interesting story how that unfolded
because we first of all got wind of the
news night interview and then of course
you're waiting for the first quotes to
drop just to see what it is and anyone
that's had any dealings with the Duke of
York did scratch their heads and wonder
whether it would be a good idea to put
him up for an hour of television being
grilled by Emily Maitlis
and when the tapes then dropped and we
saw what he said we all concluded that
we were right to have perhaps thought it
was just what he said it's what he
didn't say as well that's just what he
said I mean I'm some of the takeaways
from it you know that he couldn't have
been at tramps night club because he was
at a pizza expressing we're Woking it's
written and that he couldn't sweat and
that he was sure he hadn't had sex with
Virginia Roberts Jeffery Epstein's
accuser because that is a physical act
that he would remember and when he was
asked whether he would express regret
over the friendship and let's not forget
that he did spend four days at Epstein's
house post-conviction apparently
breaking off the friendship and he
basically said that no because he
thought he had done the honorable thing
in standing by a friend and equally
Epstein was very useful because he had
great
connections so it wasn't just the
interview itself where we saw a royal
discombobulate on screen but then the
subsequent fall out and to go from a
situation where he had apparently told
his mother at church on Sunday that it
had gone well and that it would draw a
line to four days later him releasing a
statement saying that he was stepping
back from public duty for the
foreseeable future sort of was a little
bit of a moment like the after Martha
Princess Diana's death where we were
questioning the monarchy and there were
political ramifications because if you
remember in one of the TV debates both
Johnson and Corbin were asked whether
the public should still have trust in
the monarchy or what could what could be
done with the monarchy in Corbin said
well it might be in need of improvement
so for me it was a really funny story
because this thing has been around for
what 10 years now Jeffrey Epstein scam
has been running for it for an awful
long time so why not because and I think
it's because right up to this moment
it's been
he says versus she says and actually no
one really knew the truth of the
allegations then you hear heard him has
given us over an entire and you heard he
says and a medium I thought how did you
know of it categorically denied but I
think my takeaway of of it was that you
know two years after the me to movement
to have a situation were yet again you
know a very man in a huge amount of
power and privilege is showing no
empathy for not just this victim but any
of the victims he showed no kind of
understanding about what these young and
they were girl and so if Jeffrey Epstein
had had gone through and I just thought
you know and I think quite a lot of
people it was like wow you know what a
damning indictment on those kind of
people and those circles and to just be
so sort of tone-deaf was quite stunning
I gotta move this on because we've got a
lot of different stories to go get on
the story but coming to you stick okay
and you're talking about the rise of
climate change up the I'm talking about
the future survival of our species on
the planet so it's not as important as
everything else and that to me is the
striking news story of the day what it
should be a relatively straightforward
story there is a problem with climate
change there is a problem with our
ability to take steps to deal with it is
politicized it's part of the great
culture war that we see in every other
respect and if you paused for a moment
to back away from that that is kind of
crazy that there is something that is a
it's an existential peril to everybody
maybe not now but in future generations
it's something that needs to be fixed
the science has been known for several
years you know a book came out this year
that talked about how at the end of the
1970s almost every fact that we now
cling to about climate change was known
George Bush family supremacy said don't
worry about the greenhouse effect I've
got the White House effect and then did
nothing and yet it gets mired in
politicization in culture wars in this
question of whether Greta Sundberg is a
good thing or a bad thing she was named
a Time magazine Person of the Year
extinction rebellion who while having
some noble views tend to to succumb to
every single stereotype that people want
to have about those who care about the
environment so people like Boris Johnson
can dismiss them aesthetically as
Krusty's rather than engaging with the
issues everything about this story is
crazy it's a crazy thing that it's now
2019 and we are still not engaging with
the central question of our age and I do
feel that when we look back and we talk
about the things that have been spoken
about it will be frightening and
astonishing that collectively this has
been able to be a politicized part of
the cultural committee do you think
that's right and we have heard a lot
about extinction rebellion who have
disrupted londoners some people who have
criticized their methods but but do you
welcome the impact they've had had they
had an impact well I think Blue Planet
had a major impact on people's behavior
from a consumer point of view and I
think some people in the UK kind of look
on with a sense of bewilderment because
they feel they're doing their bit they
feel that they're trying to recycle and
act responsibly and take a reusable
coffee cup and not take as many flights
and so they sort of look at extinction
rebellion getting in the way of their
daily commute and wonder whether they
are better placed protesting outside the
Chinese for Indian embassies to be
perfectly honest I
the other thing that the cult culture
was the sort of generational culture war
on this and I think it's been
fascinating about how many old men have
got so upset about Greta turn back like
to the point where that apoplectic with
rage because you knew she has got this
huge global conversation going and I
think one of the things because this
election was so dominated by brakes that
it was actually ashamed that climate
change did not get more of a hearing
because I think for a lot of
particularly younger people not just
younger people this is a really huge
pressing concern and it is slowly moving
up the priority list that people do care
about okay I'm gonna be very bossy
moveth on very quickly because we got a
couple more stories to talk about both
focusing on America and Tom you've
picked out a Donald Trump as your long
Westminster story and at the time of
recording he looks always certain to be
impeached which he is going to be
impeached this is the the man formerly
known as the leader of the free world
for only the third time in American
history in three years of American
history they are trying to sack their
president and for me it is an absolute
extraordinary sorry that that really has
been passed over I think a bit here
because Donald Trump is has some pretty
colorful opinions about him and you kind
of expect him to be impeached at some
stage in his presidency but this story
will I think dictate the outcome not
just of his current president but also
the outcome of the 2020 u.s.
presidential election if the Democrats
succeed in impeaching him and try and
convict him in the Senate when they
don't have majority then Aussie he'll no
longer be the president and successor
will obviously find it very hard to win
that president election so we'll have a
Democrat in the White House for the next
four years if however they fail I
suspect that the rebound against
Democrats that he will be able to use
and then tying up you know Washington
time and effort and bureaucracy and
shouting and screaming about essentially
a political matter that isn't really
going to affect people's already lives
that will give him a big enough bounce
to informal year so it's it will have
seismic ramifications do you think
that's right you know whatever the
outcome it's gonna have a big impact on
the election well I think of course it
will because it either finishes his
political career or it emboldened him to
Eve be even more sledge hammer like when
it comes to his approach to American
politics but I think because the Senate
is weighted in his favor this seems like
a bit of a
and it seems to be a foregone conclusion
that the Senate will back him the
Republican back Senate will back in so
then it looks like it's a bit of a
sideshow or that it's basically the
Democrats attempt once again to
basically thought the president that
they've never supported and they've
tried to use perhaps legitimately every
trick in the book to get rid of it's not
going to convince anyone new people in
America you will fear will have form
their opinions on this again one
American president being accused of
being in the pocket of a foreign
government should in theory in America
the end of the games the worst thing you
can ever say about a pet president of
American are being in in hock to Russia
remember the charges the charges are not
that he was cooperating the Russians it
that he was withholding four hundred
million u.s. dollars in military aid
from the new Ukrainian president
vladimir Lansky which I used to practice
and finally got it right
it's a phony enormous bribe he's using
taxpayers money to bribe try and go
after his it was a perfect phone call
there was no quid pro quo and no pretty
limited so bizarrely the facts aren't in
dispute it's a strange story because
they really hate Joe Biden and his son
and a banker Trump so did a tweet saying
it's unbelievable that Joe Biden's son
got a job and he had no qualifications
you're like whoa that is amazing
and I usually gonna stick with you
actually because you've picked out an
element of Donald Trump's year as well
haven't you so you know Donald Trump
many of us have felt for a long time has
peddled a lot of xenophobia bigotry
Islamophobia racism and that all
crystallized this year when he told
three RT for minority Democratic
congresswoman known as the squad and to
go back home to their broken and
crime-infested places and I think that
was quite a watershed moment because it
did show that without any doubt the true
character of this person the fact that
you know to say to people by the way
they were all born in the United States
of America they're all American citizens
but that was like a reveal into his
mentality which is if you don't look
like me then you have a really American
and that you should go home and any
person of color to be told to go home as
one of the most offensive
things possible particularly when
they're born in that country well that's
right three out of the four born in the
country all four American citizens we
are going to wrap it up of this section
for the time being but plenty more still
to come so do stay with us celebration
and scorn as the team picked their
heroes and villains of the year coming
up after the break welcome back this is
year in review on Sky News we're
discussing the highs and lows of 2019
with the editor of The Times Literary
Supplement stable the Telegraph's
associate editor commander Tom Oni the
sons political editor Tom Newton done
and the editor of The Londoner at the
Evening Standard Aisha has arica so
welcome back to all of you so let's turn
our attention now to the stories that
made our guests cheer and cheer it's
their heroes and villains of 2019 stick
I'm going to come to you first your hero
is Dominic Cummings and your villainous
Dominic Cummings explain well I mean
he's not my hair in the sense of it's
not someone who's whose philosophy or
indeed the consequence of his philosophy
I massively applaud but I think you have
to accept that he was the dominant
figure one of the dominant figures that
is led from the outer chaos that began
the year in terms of what was gonna
happen to brexit we would look like we
were stuck into into horrible stasis to
where we are now which is we're pursuing
bricks it with clear bigger and clearer
directions so anyone who supports brexit
Dominic Cummings is unquestionably a
hero
anyone who admires middle-aged men who
dressed scruffa Lee I see this is you're
all terrible
Britten's dress sexy dresses like he's
that he's sort of almost a hipster but
isn't quite he sort of just fallen out
of bed at 4:00 in the morning I admire
that for the reasons that won't need any
further explanation so he the hero and
that was a the villainous side is that
he seems to me to epitomize a certain
type of politics in this country the
very very end oriented which says we
don't care what we break in order to get
what we want and you saw it with the
vote leave campaign he famously had say
three things whatever they act question
is say the same three things it does not
matter if they are true or not we are
repeatedly going to say them
then people will hear what we're saying
in this NGO he was perfectly willing to
crash Parliament poverty when to crash
all sorts of institutions now people may
say they are there to be crushed they
are there to be subverted but he is
purely driven goal driven and if you
don't share those goals he will appear
to be an utter villain instrument from
you Tom do you think that's fair
criticism for starters and how much
credit can he take for the achievements
that of Boris Johnson this year I think
there's both fair credit and fair
Chris's emotion I wouldn't quite agree
with SIG's very own sort of dress sense
and neither Dominic Cummings I think you
can wear a shirt when he press reviews
as well as going to but without a doubt
he is the central figure
along with Boris Johnson he's set the
weather he's behind pretty much every
single political you story we've had and
you know like him all loathe him and
there's good reasons to both you've got
to give us him okay I usually gonna move
to you at your hero so this was a Muslim
lady who was on a tube train and she
stood up to a man who was hurling very
vicious horrible quite frightening
anti-semitic abuse at a Jewish man and
his children and the the the person he
was making the abuse was actually quite
frightening but she stood up to him and
I think it was just a moment of real
courage and anti-semitism has been a
growing problem in the last a couple of
years
we're seeing an wider society we've
actually seen in the Labor Party it's
been a huge issue driven out some very
very important MPs like Luciana bersia
and what I loved about this story is
often M Muslims and Jews are being pit
against each other so it was fantastic
to see sort of this woman stand up for
somebody and it's not just anti-semitism
we're seeing the rise of Islamophobia as
well we've got a lot of that in the
Conservative Party at the moment and I
just felt in a year of a lot of division
of a lot of kind of hatred and community
sort of fighting with each other it was
great to see sort of two people from two
different communities kind of coming
together to look after each other and
your villain is on the same theme yeah I
think one of the things that has
polluted politics has been the rise of
not the rise but just the
proliferation of online trolling now
social media has been good in some
senses it has democratized politics it's
allowed everybody to have a goal but it
has also allowed this horrible toxic
nasty bullying culture where if you
don't like somebody you can't have a
civil disagreement you have to try and
silence them you have to threaten them
you have to frighten them into silence I
think that's a very very dangerous thing
for knowledge licks are active on social
media if you noticed it's got a lot
worse this year it's always been quite
bad and I just think we've kind of gone
through that now and just blocking and
muting and frankly ignoring is the best
approach I think when Twitter first came
about it was this wonderfully kind of
like quirky thing where people put up
interesting posts and everyone kind of
engaged and then it became so toxic that
we've now gone full circle like the most
toxic people are just the most
irrelevant now and therefore one needs
to kind of have it's terrible when
people come off Twitter they say well I
can't cope with this I just think the
more moderate and constructive the
people are on Twitter the less space
there is for the morons who just are
vile to be I don't agree with I think
has a real-world impact I think what's
happening social medias people say
things on social media which they would
never say to your face it's a great
argument if you follow that through its
logical conclusion the more people feel
comfortable saying it on Twitter then
more they will become comfortable saying
it to your face
and I think either human beings have got
worse
or actually we've revealed something
that's always been there in people once
you've revealed that once you've opened
the gates for people to abandon all
social norms all sense of responsibility
I don't think you can never get that
back and I think that does have a
real-world effect and you remind me of
if you really are bored one day and you
want to engage with your trolls it's a
remarkable thing someone saw something
highly abusive to you but whatever it is
and if you don't reply to them say well
that's a bit unfair a bit harsh use
didn't they say once it mean to thank
you and it's on to this a humane
interesting cause I don't get that with
my trolls basically your life
spend all my time doing every night
That's not me but just me I'm just
trolling you I came here to become to
your choice of hero now and a really
positive story this I just got a smile
on my face just thinking about it
because I like to be transported back to
the summer and watching Ben Stokes in
the Cricket World Cup final and bearing
in mind that he had villain status
because of the brawl that he was
involved in and there was even talk of
him not being put in the squad and from
the very beginning of the tournament
that amazing catch which I think saw him
crowned player of that particular match
and then of course that final over
against New Zealand and everyone just
being completely gripped even if you
didn't watch cricket are you one of
these people who say I can't watch it
because I just don't understand it you
saw that raw sporting ability out there
and just the psychological strength that
it would have required to get through
that over and to score two sixes I think
was phenomenally unpatriotic what it was
a draw by any sense of sporting fairness
the cricketing gonna wave a tremendous
ceiling and also by the way just say
that if we wanted to be confirmed this
wasn't just some kind of one-off
we then saw his performance in the ashes
where he turned that third Test around
I just think rightly crown the Sports
Personality of the year because it was
just the most amazing and inspiring
sporting performance that I think I've
ever seen okay and we're gonna move you
on to your villain now yeah it's
probably not one for cricket necessarily
Jeremy Corbyn and I say villain although
I think fundamentally he is a decent
human being and a politician I think
he's been revealed to be villainous just
in the most recent days and weak in the
sense of him projecting himself as a
different kind of politician and let's
not even get into gentle and kind of
politics which isn't necessarily
espoused by some of his most fanatical
followers but it's a sense that he was
something different and yet in this
clinging to power in this refusal to
stand down he said not going not he said
he's going but I find it frankly
ridiculous that he is still there
you look at Kinnick you look at Miliband
you look at others who have failed
before they categorically apologize and
yet Corbin didn't even say sorry for
three days to his own staffers who were
left in labor HQ wondering what was
happening to their jobs this is meant to
be a champion of the workers and I just
think it's such a hypocritical
contradiction that the so-called
politician of the people wasn't able to
admit that he was revealed to be as
cravenly self-interested as the average
party leader and I think that has been
the great tragedy of this that so much
we won the I was invested in this
different kind of MP that could try and
take politics to a different level and
in fact he was just revealed to be
vainglorious arrogant and self-pitying
and I think that's a drag and one of the
things which I think members are very
very worried about is the fact that
because he is staying on will the
contest for his successor be a free and
fair contest or will his hand you know
still hover over trying to sort of shape
the outcome which is again not my style
absolutely which again as you see that's
not what you think is best for the
coalition belief in a project that he
thinks is best for the country basically
explains why he lost the ideology has
been trumped by the majority collective
deciding that they didn't like him or
his ideas okay we come to you Tom and
your hero now a couple of heroes I
thought free in total and they were the
heroes of London Bridge terrorist attack
reasonably recently and tragically
Britain is now unfortunately used to
terrorist acts we've seen it on TV we've
seen it on smartphone version we know
how these things play out and we know
the ghastly results and this what
happened in London bridges world with
that by the hand of husband can't could
have been very more very much more
ghastly than it was if it wasn't for
three incredibly brave people one a chef
working in fishmongers Hall who tackled
husband can't despite the fight he was
stabbed five times himself and then two
more who ran outside and tackled him
with of all things a whale's horn they
might have pull off the wall
and a fire extinguisher and they
disarmed him and pinned him down long
enough for the police to turn up and
deal with him as we all know what
happened there but it was just true
British honorable grit out of nowhere
built on bitter experience of what
happens and they save lives and ponies
can say not only the British and we
should remember the victims of course as
well shouldn't we Jack maraton and
Saskia James who so sad they lost their
lives in that attack let's move on to
your villains my villains again
multifold and I was certainly widen out
from online trolls to say the entirety
of big tech that's all a lot of them so
the likes of Facebook Twitter YouTube
and I think 2019 has been a truly awful
year for them you think of again another
awful terror attack Christchurch the
massacre in Christ rocket leading run
around with a gun that was live streamed
on Facebook undoubtedly
a thing that encouraged him to do what
he do because he got a thrill out of
life screaming mass murder to the world
Facebook had allowed that to happen
online bullying on things like Instagram
but also all the fake news is prevent
Twitter with no one thinking a
responsibility to stop it simply because
it harms their business model it is
utterly abhorrent and I sincerely hope
and I'm also now suspect the 2019 is the
last year this is allowed to happen 2020
is going to be the year of social media
regulation and companies like Facebook
would say of course we don't want things
like that to happen it's just incredibly
hard to police so much yes it goes on
year after year after year and frayed
their answers is simply incredible it's
time for governments to step in okay
we believe it there thank you all do
stay with us though when we come back
our panel are going to gaze into their
crystal balls to predict the stories
that we'll be talking about next year so
join us after the break
welcome back to our final part of our
Year in Review
so having looked back at 2019 let's now
look forward to 2020 and our panel's
predictions for the year to come
and I say you're all very brave
obviously I usually let's start with you
Scotland for me so Boris Johnson didn't
win across the whole of the United
Kingdom there was another big winner at
the election that was Nicola Sturgeon
and it's quite interesting because they
are really the two kind of opposing
leaders in the the country and she is
going to square up to him definitely in
2020 and the issue of a second
referendum on Scottish independence is
going to be something that she will
really really push so she is pretty
strong at the moment however there is a
big trial coming up in Scotland which is
going to be a huge huge deal this is M
Alex Salmond and it relates to M sexual
offences which he denies but it's going
to be a very very big case and there's
quite a lot of speculation about what
the future might be for Nicola Sturgeon
and there's even rumors swirling around
that maybe she may leave Scottish
politics and maybe go off to do
something in the United Nations on
climate change is a very big climate
change conference happening in Scotland
next year she's done a lot of work in
this area but whatever happens Scotland
is going to be a very very interesting
place to watch because they did not
succumb to the charms of Boris Johnson
well yes and what do you think Tom do
you think that he would just hold his
line say no second independence
referendum will there be real pressure
on him to change his mother's gonna win
this tussle quite simply because Nicola
Sturgeon will shout and scream and
that's exactly what she should be doing
because she wants to ferment
dissatisfaction in Scotland with the
Union and with England but Boris Johnson
has the legal right to say no and refuse
and as long as the poles still roughish
a reasonable majority in favour of the
union roughly 55 45 at the moment I
think you have narrowed they have now
not by much it's still a majority
support for the Union and as long as
that continues until we got to stay with
you and stay with politics because your
predict
involves labor actually my prediction is
the rise of a brand-new centrist party
that succeeds no no just wait for it
wait for it so last year I predicted the
demise of Boris Johnson - so right a
centrist party will emerge and it will
become the official opposition and I
tell you how labor gonna liked a Corbin
Easter in the in the shape of Jamie
Corbin almost certainly Rebecca Don
Bailey in my view because their
membership is still substantially quite
left-wing and then it disapprove of
Jeremy Corbyn at all so they will elect
someone in jeremy corbyn's like this
will precipitate a mass revolt amongst
all those centuries labour in peace
quite a few of them left who will having
learnt from the lessons of the last two
three four years they will walk and they
will walk on mass centrist parties felt
previously because not all of them
walked way and here's the beauty at all
there are two hundred three Labour MPs
at the moment if a hundred and two in
other words majority one leave then they
will be officially crowned the Official
Opposition and the Labour Party will be
the third party home load Tom well
listen I put myself on that on the line
deep enough as it is exactly nowhere
with you but a figure like you know Jess
Phillips Rachel Reeves you know moderate
Labour MP liked popular who can
communicate with the country it's gonna
be interesting next year when we see
what did happen was it back to prove it
easy you've got to bring him back we
will of course we come to your
prediction now yeah I don't know how
controversial this is I think Donald
Trump will lose the US election and I
think the reason why even that sounds
Patricia at one level he has because
he's the incumbent there's normally
biased towards them if the American
economy is doing well as it is at the
minute he should be well ahead I feel
he's still going to lose I don't think
impeachment matters either way I think
he if you look at the midterms he did
not do well in the places that he needed
to do well if you look at his popularity
rating it is as bad as it has ever been
he only snuck through because he was
underestimated he won in a couple of
states he lost the popular vote to a
large extent I still feel that America
this is a fork in the road election when
I talked about climate change earlier we
are going to have either a president in
the White House who
believes that such a thing as climate
change exists and will take steps to
stop it or you'll have Donald Trump who
will do nothing this is a hugely
significant moment for the world and I
think Americans the middle class of
America will eventually rise up and say
we are not going to be a laughingstock
for eight years we're going to be a
laughingstock for four and they're going
to stop it now and Donald Trump will
lose and then may refuse to leave the
White House for a while what do you all
make of that I think you will stay in
office I don't think he'll be found
guilty and I think that will allow him
to kind of really stimulate his base
because he can say look all of these
opponents tried to come and get me
I always said they would they're the
establishment this is all about draining
the swamp and I think that will make his
base come out for him and I think that
means he could win the next election I
suppose will come down to the economy so
if the economy continues to do okay then
middle of America enemy places that you
know Pennsylvania and Michigan these
sort of Rust Belt swing states that
deliver for first time around they'll
continue to vote from again in fact I
think they probably will and I offer
Stieg 50 quit bet here and now with the
winner it was a hundred quid with two to
one I'm now resigning from that they
made quite a good argument posture
tragedy 50 quid I'll take it out okay
you heard it here one more quick
question before we move on so who's
gonna win because we've got a big race
I think they might go play safe and go
for sleepy Joe Biden um because I think
there was Donald Trump's what yeah I
think they'll look at possibly the
British election and say there's a lot
of time to pursue left and they'll go
for someone who is broadly centrist no
go for Joe Biden okay well another
interesting prediction there for us to
pick over time and come in a finally we
comment to you and of course um the
Olympics coming up yes which is come
around very quickly again so it didn't
Tokyo I know and actually it's
interesting that recently a survey came
out which suggested that 2012 was Brits
favorite year in the last decade and I
think we all understand why that was
because of the triumphant jubilation of
that competition for us but we've been
doing a lot to promote women's sport on
the Telegraph and I've just got into
Deena ashes
myth from reading an interview in the
magazine that one of my colleagues did
with her quite a long time ago and I was
just so impressed by this athlete 24
years old she was in Doha in the summer
smashed both of her pb's became the
world champion in the 200 meters and I
just think I don't want to tempt fate
but she could end up being the poster
girl and the star of the Olympics and
what a brilliant thing that would be
from women's sport we've had a huge
amount of a very positive dialogue
around women's football because of the
World Cup and I just think that if we
can have our most successful female
sprinter make her mark in 2020 that
could be a brilliant thing that could
open doors and what a role model this
lady is not only absolutely phenomenal
in her own sport and improving all the
time but really learned and considered
she got a BA degree from King's College
in history she's really into being all
rounded and I think schoolgirls who
might be competing next year at sports
day will be looking up to her and
putting her on a pedestal and I hope she
is physically on one
I hope she's physically on the pedestal
for a gold medal of a let's wait and see
you know make up wonderfully for England
getting knocked out of yet another euro
competition about 57th yes if the men
are out Shaun by the women that could be
a great that's fun but it would be nice
if the women could get some of the pee
that the men get a situation that might
be a debate for another day so yeah
underestimate that the feel-good factor
that that wins like that could engender
if they do have those that committer is
a royal correspondent a political
correspondent and a sports content I
think we should just be silent do you
know what if you've covered the Royals
and politics in 2019 sport has been the
perfect antidote
that's why I've been so gosu multitasker
there's a media multitasker well you are
all the multitaskers to me and I really
appreciate it Chris but happy new year
everyone
it is indeed happy new decade will
indeed that's so true what do we caught
up with the 20's obviously naughties and
20s okay once we are out of time with
Ntaganda Sonny knows I'm pleased to say
and we're coming to the end of year in
review so my thanks to stick Camilla Tom
and iishe
and we'll see you all soon on the press
preview but for now from all of us
seasonal good wishes and good bye
[Music]
you